this video was brought to you by fetch
rewards if you like getting gift cards
and other cool prizes
for free then you've got to download
fetch rewards more about them in a bit
throughout 1932 and the first half of
1933 there was a small-time criminal
outfit
known back then as the baro gang active
in the region surrounding the city of
dallas they were just a tiny blip on the
radar known mainly in texas and the
surrounding states but
one chance raid in missouri would change
all of that
in april 1933 police officers in joplin
missouri busted an apartment in town
believing that it was being used by
bootleggers
it wasn't not then anyway as it happened
it was the current hideout of the barrow
gang
a shootout ensued all the criminals got
away but two police officers were killed
there was something else the gang had
left behind a camera and rolls of
undeveloped film police found
photographs of the outlaws smiling and
posing in front of their car
and showing off their guns it was a sign
of criminals that america had not really
seen before it made the barrow gang
unique but two members
stood out from the rest the young couple
of bonnie parker
and clyde barrow this picture of bonnie
in particular gun in hand cigar in mouth
became iconic and was planted on the
front page of almost
every newspaper in the country so what
made bonnie and clyde
so captivating some argued that it was a
matter
of the right place and the right time
thanks to the great depression americans
expected escapism from the media
something
to take their minds off the distressing
reality of their lives
they sought entertainment by reading
about the exploits of movie stars sports
heroes and
yes even infamous outlaws like john
dillinger but for the duration of their
spree
few if any other public figures were as
memorable controversial
and romanticized as bonnie and clyde
[Music]
this story begins on march 24 1909 near
teleco texas just southeast of dallas
where
clyde chestnut barrow was born into a
poor farming family a drought forced
clyde's father henry to close down the
farm and in 1922 clyde barrow and his
parents and six siblings packed up and
moved to dallas
when he was young clyde had musical
aspirations he used to play an old
guitar back on the farm and
later taught himself to play the
saxophone and kept playing it until the
very end
after his death one such musical
instrument was recovered from their
infamous bullet-ridden death car
barrow also had an admiration for the
united states navy and even had a
usn tattoo on his arm even though he
never served he tried to enlist as a
teenager
was rejected on medical grounds we're
not sure what the reason was but it is
possible
he still suffered from the lingering
effects of a debilitating illness that
he had as a child
probably yellow fever or malaria
whatever honorable ambitions clyde
entertained as a young man they started
falling more and more by the wayside as
he began hanging out with his older
brother
ivan barrow better known as buck who had
no desire to walk the straight and
narrow
bucket dropped out of school when he was
still a child and had already embarked
on a life of crime by the time he became
a teenager under his influence glyde
also began committing minor crimes
starting out with petty thievery his
final arrest was in 1926 when he was 17
years old the record said that he was
guilty of automobile theft although in
reality clyde had failed to return a
rental car on time and eventually the
rental agency
dropped the charges his next caper came
just a few weeks later when klein and
buck were caught
trying to sell a truckload of stolen
turkeys from then on clyde barrow fully
embraced his new criminal career
as he escalated to stealing cars and
then to armed robbery becoming a wanted
fugitive
on the run from the law by the time he
turned 20.
meanwhile bonnie elizabeth parker was
born on october 1st 1910 in rowena texas
the
second of three children to charles and
emma parker in 1914 charles parker
passed away and bonnie's mother moved
the family to dallas to live with their
grandparents in a poor neighborhood
known as cement city
like clyde barrow bonnie parker showed
no inclinations for crime when she was
young she was in fact an honor student
who enjoyed writing poetry and
performing in talent shows with
dreams of one day becoming a famous
movie star we suppose she
ultimately got what she wanted in a
monkey pool-wish sort of way
not many actors from that era are still
famous today but the names bonnie and
clyde
live on in infamy in september 1926 just
a few days before turning 16 years old
bonnie married her high school
sweetheart
a boy named roy thornton but he didn't
turn out to be a very nice man and he
abused bonnie both physically and
mentally the marriage fell apart and
eventually bonnie left him and moved him
with her grandmother finding work as a
waitress at a diner named marco's cafe
meanwhile thornton was sentenced to five
years in prison for robbery in 1929.
they never divorced so bonnie was still
technically
married to thornton while on the run
with clyde she was still actually
wearing her wedding ring when she was
gunned down given her relationships with
men like thornton and barrow it has been
speculated that bonnie suffered from a
clinical syndrome
called hybristophilia which is an
attraction to people who commit violent
crimes
nowadays we're very familiar with the
phenomenon thanks mainly to the groupies
who fall in love with serial killers and
send them gifts and love letters in
prison some criminals like ted bundy and
richard ramirez the night stalker
even married their admirers but back
then it was still a relatively new
concept
unofficially it has become known as
bonnie and clyde syndrome
everything changed for bonnie parker the
day she met clyde barrow there are
multiple accounts of
how the event happened but most agree
that the two met through a common
acquaintance in january 1930. bonnie was
19 years old still working as a waitress
while
clyde was a year older and already
wanted by the police on multiple charges
of car
theft by all accounts it was love at
first sight and the two became
inseparable for the next few weeks
however their budding romance was cut
short when barrow was arrested and sent
to eastern prison farm in houston county
in april 1930.
his initial stay was a short one clyde
convinced bonnie who up until that point
had never broken the law
to smuggle a gun to him so that he could
break out she did so and barrow did
manage to escape albeit briefly before
he was recaptured and sent back
this time with an increased sentence of
14 years
the time spent at eastern was a
formative experience for clyde barrow
and
those who knew him said that it was what
turned him from a minor criminal to an
embittered hate-filled killer
or from schoolboy to a rattlesnake as
one of his accomplices put it
while in prison barrow was the target of
repeated beatings and rapes at the hands
of another inmate named ed crowder
these continued until clyde lured
crowder into the toilets one night and
beat him to death with a lead pipe
thus committing his first murder he was
never charged with it though allegedly
because
another inmate was already serving a
life sentence and agreed to take the
blame
eastham was a hell hole for barrow
besides crowd as assaults he
also had to contend with hard labor and
abuse from the gods
after over a year and a half inside
clyde decided that he would go
to drastic measures in order to escape
the work detail and had another inmate
chop off two of his toes with an axe
what he did not know was that while he
was incarcerated his mother had been
petitioning the governor to grant him an
early release the governor finally
relented and clyde barrow was released
from easton in february 1932
six days after he cut off his toes in a
little display of uniformity bonnie
suffered her own leg injury although
hers was significantly worse while
barrow was only left slightly hobbled
parker's injury was so bad that at times
she couldn't walk at all and
she needed clyde to carry her this
happened over a year later but we might
as well mention it now
in the summer of 1933 the gang got into
a car accident after barrow missed a
detour sign for
a road under construction and crashed
the vehicle into a dry riverbed
the car battery smashed a bits and
squirted acid all over body's right leg
because they were fugitives they
couldn't go to a proper doctor so
instead they improvised a quick
treatment with baking soda and salve
and the leg never healed right so look
you probably know that bonnie and clyde
are about to start
robbing and stealing everything that's
not nailed down now i'd never recommend
that you become a professional criminal
but one thing
that might give you that slick rush of
getting free stuff is today sponsor
fetch rewards and how about that for a
transition fetch is a brilliantly simple
app that gives you rewards
for free sounds too good to be true
right and you're probably thinking well
simon
i've been through this before i'm going
to have to take a bunch of surveys or
buy a 5 000
toaster oven that's supposed to run on
solar power and then they give me a 20
gift card to bed bath and beyond or
something like that
well if that's what you're thinking
you're absolutely wrong soften
your heart and heart my fellow skeptics
because this is different fetch doesn't
ask you to do anything new just follow
through with the normal shopping you
already do then scan
the receipts into the app that's it
going grocery shopping
scan it go into the more scanning go
into everyone's favorite video game
retailer because you just bought
stockiness and you want to seem
committed
seems questionable but i'm not judging
scan that receipt and enjoy your new
playstation game you can even scan
amazon purchases and e-receipts while
you're scanning all these receipts
you're earning big rewards
turn those points in for i don't know
maybe an amazon gift card
you can spend however you want or maybe
you're like me and you want to splurge
on some
delicious kentucky fried chicken
this is a great opportunity to score
some free stuff so if you want to
cash in on the shopping you're already
doing go ahead and check out the link in
the description
below and right now you guys can
download the app and use the code
biographics to get an extra 4 000 points
when you scan your first receipt
fantastic and let's get back to body and
clyde
while at eastern clyde barrow befriended
another young inmate named ralph fultz
bonding over their hatred of the prison
the two agreed that one day they would
take revenge on eastern by
raiding the prison killing the guards
and releasing the inmates fultz was
paroled in 1931
and once both men were free they
reunited on the outside and formed a
gang alongside bonnie parker
and another friend of barros named
raymond hamilton this was the
original incarnation of the burrow gang
although
bonnie never previously displayed any
inclination for breaking the law she
also never questioned clyde and
eagerly went along with anything he
wanted to do some of the other surviving
gang members pointed out the bonnie was
completely subservient to him in stark
contrast to the image created of her by
the media with bonnie being some kind of
ruthless outlaw mastermind with some
even proclaiming her to be the brains of
the outfit while
barrow was the muscle a few quick notes
about ralph
faltz though he was the longest lived
member of the barrow gang he was
one of the few who managed to make it
out of the so-called public enemy era
and even turn his life around he was the
main source for clyde barrow's time at
eastham and
only disclosed these details decades
after clyde's death
fultz lived until 1993 and died aged 82.
anyway when clyde was released from
prison he hooked up with bonnie
fultz and hamilton and immediately went
back to his criminal ways
this brings us to another myth that
surrounds bonnie and clyde they might be
remembered as notorious bank robbers but
they didn't actually
rob that many banks preferring instead
low risk targets like grocery stores gas
stations and hardware stores
even when they did target a bank it was
usually a small town one these were
hardly
crime of the century material and it's
more likely that if the gang hadn't left
behind the camera with their photographs
on that fateful day in joplin missouri
today none of us would have any idea who
bonnie and clyde even were
this version of the barragang did not
last long in march 1932 they botched a
robbery at a hardware store in kaufman
texas while
attempting a quick getaway they crashed
the car and had to escape on foot
barrow and hamilton was successful but
bonnie and ralph faults were captured
fultz was convicted and sentenced to 10
years meanwhile bonnie who had a clean
record was released in june 1932
after only a few months in prison while
she was incarcerated barrow continued
his crime spree with hamilton they
committed their first murder in april
when they shot a merchant named j.w
butcher in hillsborough texas just a few
months later they killed their first
police officer in stringtown oklahoma
when deputy sheriff eugene moore tried
to arrest
them for having an open bottle of
whiskey in the car the barrow gang
certainly made it clear time and time
again
that they had no qualms when it came to
murder the fbi claimed that they
committed 13 murders in all including
nine police officers
although who exactly killed them remains
unclear to this day
when bonnie was released from prison she
immediately went in search of clyde and
the two reunited a few weeks later even
though most sources say that she never
actually shot anybody or even carried a
gun for that matter
she was clearly unperturbed by the fact
that clyde had begun killing people in
cold blood raymond hamilton
left the gang a few months later he was
eventually captured independently and
sentenced for murder he was executed by
electric chair in 1935
he was 20 years old by november 1932
hamilton had been replaced in the gang
by william daniel jones who went by wd
or deacon he knew the barriers since
they were kids and looked up to clyde
and
even though he was only 16 years old he
didn't hesitate to use guns
and may have already killed a man by the
time he joined he certainly killed a few
after
in early 1933 clyde's older brother buck
was released from prison and he quickly
joined up with the gang and
he also brought along his wife blanche
barrow these were the five that made up
the classic lineup of the group if you
will
the version that existed after joplin
missouri when the entire country learned
of the barrow gang even though
their attention was almost exclusively
centered on bonnie and clyde
[Music]
this version of the gang was not exactly
long-lived either buck and blanche
joined in late march 1933.
just a few months later one of them was
dead and the other was in prison
the event in joplin missouri brought the
gang national in for me and while this
caused a certain sense of added
excitement from a practical perspective
it also made life on the run much harder
they were more recognizable now that
their photos had been shown all over the
country
for the most part they had to avoid
motels and restaurants instead sleeping
in the car or by a campfire moreover in
may of that year the fbi joined in the
manhunt after gathering evidence that
the group had driven a stolen car across
state lines
there were a few close calls one after
another and all of them ended in violent
shootouts
first there was the aforementioned
gunfight in joplin in april that left
two officers dead
then two months later on july 20th there
was another shootout at the cabins of
the red crown tourist court in
platte city missouri nobody was killed
but buck barrow was shot and gravely
injured then
just four days later the gang was
involved in another gunfight in dexter
iowa
buck was hit again and both he and his
wife blanche were captured buckbarrow
died of his wounds after just a few days
while
lance was sentenced to 10 years in
prison she was released after serving
six years changed her name and
married a man named eddie frazier and
started a new life for herself she died
in 1988 at the age of 77.
next up to leave the gang was deacon
jones during one shootout there was a
point when it was just him and bonnie
hiding in a bush
she thought clyde had been killed and
she lamented the fact that they didn't
have a gun
so she could die with him as it turned
out clyde was fine he caught up to them
and they made their getaway but it was
moments like this that convinced jones
that as far as bonnie and clyde were
concerned
the only way to go out was a hail of
bullets jones was the youngest of the
bunch and he was still a minor at the
time
he might have been deeply loyal to
bonnie and clyde but he didn't share
their death wish
in september they parted ways although
the exact circumstances are uncertain
one version said they parted amicably
and
that clyde even coached him up on what
to say if he got caught telling him to
blame all the murders on him and buck
another version says that jones took the
car to put gas in it and instead of
returning he just kept on driving
jones didn't really have the smarts to
make it on his own so predictably
he eventually returned home where he was
identified and arrested in november
now came the difficult task of seeing
exactly what they could charge him with
ultimately jones accepted a deal which
saw him charged with one murder without
malice in texas or
manslaughter as we call it today and
this protected him from being extradited
to other states to stand trial for other
crimes
he was sentenced to 15 years and got out
after six
after that he mostly kept a low profile
barring one resurgence in the late 1960s
the bonnie and clyde movie came out in
1967 with warren bertie and faye dunaway
generating renewed interest in the
outlaws deacon jones took advantage
of his newfound fame by giving a candid
interview to playboy magazine about life
on the run with bonnie and clyde he died
in 1974 during an altercation after
being
blasted with a shotgun
with jones gone now it was finally just
bonnie and clyde on the run together
although
they probably enjoyed being alone there
were some practical problems that came
along with it the hits got smaller as it
was only clyde
doing the robbing as bonnie couldn't
even act as a getaway driver due to a
debilitating leg injury therefore clyde
decided to do something he had been
planning for years
a raid on eastern prison that way he
would hit two birds with one stone he
would get revenge on the place he
probably hated most in the world
and he would also find some new recruits
to join his gang
easton was a prison farm it wasn't some
kind of maximum security prison with
giant concrete walls instead the main
security measures consisted of barbed
wire fences patrols and
guard dogs one of the men currently
incarcerated at eastern was
raymond hamilton one of the former
barrow gang members so clyde enlisted
the help of his brother floyd to
organize the breakout
a few days before the raid floyd and
another man named jimmy mullen stuck
inside the perimeter of the prison and
hid some weapons and ammo inside an
inner tube left near a culvert the
following day floyd visited his brother
in prison and told him the plan
raymond hamilton knew where the guns
were knew where the getaway car would be
waiting
and he had a few days time to find a
couple of extra inmates willing to take
part in the prison escape the breakout
occurred on january 16th 1934 it was
hamilton and four other prisoners but
the important one was henry methvin who
agreed to join the barrow gang following
the escape alongside hamilton
the other three went their separate ways
and were all eventually recaptured
during the breakout one of the escapees
joe palmer killed a guard named
major krausen two other guards abandoned
their post and almost allowed a
widespread escape
the whole event greatly angered colonel
lee simmons the general manager for the
whole texas prison system he wanted
bonnie and clyde and he didn't want them
captured he wanted them dead
simmons reached out to a retired texas
park ranger named frank hammer who had a
reputation not only as a tough and
skilled investigator
but also as someone who never shied away
from using deadly force
simmons persuaded hammer to lead the
manhunt against the outlaws and
gave him a commission as a highway
patrolman he even formed his own squad
to do it
[Music]
this new incarnation of the barrow gang
killed another three law enforcement
agents during their short criminal spree
raymond hamilton was the first to leave
the group henry method also got left
behind on one occasion when clyde saw a
patrol car and
drove off in a hurry this was in
louisiana which was
also where methvin's parents lived there
are a few conflicting stories over what
happened next particularly
when it came to methvin's involvement
basically the authorities approached his
father with a deal helped catch bonnie
and clyde
and henry would avoid the death penalty
another version said that
it was methvin himself who made the deal
in exchange for a complete pardon from
the state of texas although he was later
tried for murder in oklahoma the point
is that either one or the other or both
of the messelin men
agreed to help set up an ambush for the
outlaw couple
it was may 23 1934 around nine in the
morning bonnie and clyde were inside a
stolen ford v8
driving across a bumpy back country road
on the way to the methvin household what
they didn't know was that frank hammer
and his posse was waiting in the bushes
for their arrival
according to one version ivan methvin
henry's father
even parked his own car by the side of
the road as if he was having engine
troubles so clyde would stop to talk to
him when this happened
the lorman sprang out of the bushes and
began unloading on the car with
everything he had
to say that it was overkill would be an
understatement one lawman described the
scene although
he made no mention of ivan methane being
there each of us six officers had a
shotgun and an automatic rifle and
pistols
we opened fire with the automatic rifles
they were emptied before the car
even got with us then we used shotguns
after shooting the shotguns we emptied
the pistols at the car which had passed
us and ran into a ditch about 50 yards
on down the road
it almost turned over we kept shooting
at the car even after it stopped
we weren't taking any chances close to
150 rounds turned the car into swiss
cheese
according to the coroner's report 17 of
those rounds went into clyde and 26 into
bonnie the undertaker later confessed
that working on their bodies proved
extra difficult because
the embalming fluid kept leaking out of
the holes bonnie and clyde were dead
they were about as
dead as you could get people flocked to
the streets as
the car was towed into town with the
body still inside today it's a museum
piece in prim nevada and
has been on display in exhibits all over
the country tens of thousands of people
showed up for their funerals revealing
the
true extent of the fascination that the
country had with these two outlaws
shortly before her death bonnie parker
sent her mother a new poem that she
wrote titled
the trail's end which finished in a
prophetic way
someday they'll go down together they'll
bury them side by side
to few it'll be grief to the law
a relief but it's death for bonnie and
clyde
so i really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below don't forget
to subscribe please do check out our
fantastic sponsor fetch link below
and thank you for watching
bye